- So your book is called
Very Fat, Very Brave.
and I think I'm kind of aware
where the title comes from
because I'm a fan of
yours, but for everybody
that doesn't know, why did
you, why did you title it that?
- So when a fat woman
posts on the internet
a picture of themselves in a bikini
or something revealing, the internet goes,
my God, you're so brave!
Which is the fully
insane thing to be like,
somebody who's wearing a bathing suit
to go swimming is brave?
No, they're just wearing
the correct articles
of clothing to do an activity.
- Well, and it's almost
insulting because--
- Oh, it's fully insulting.
- I always loved that.
And they're like, oh, you're so confident.
You just don't care.
And I'm like, what?
(laughing)
- That's just you don't
care because I'm like,
I spent hours!
- And like, I care about things.
Maybe just know things
that you find important.
But I was like, let's not
write me off like that.
It's funny how they they're
like, Oh, you're so confident.
I'm like, I'm not confident.
I'm just like, being.
- Yes, yes.
It's so frustrating.
So it's very tongue in cheek.
I don't think I'm actually brave,
but like, I would love to
meet somebody who was like--
(grunting)
She actually thinks she's
brave for being in a bikini?
Like, I want to meet
that person to be like.
- (laughing) I wanna have
coffee with that person.
Well, in the book, you have
a way of dealing with haters
and I want you to tell
everybody what that is.
- Oh, I have so many different ways.
- I have a particular
favorite, but you go ahead.
- Wait, which one is your favorite?
- I like whenever you say that,
because this is my thing I always say,
I think that's why I relate to it.
I'm like, do you have that
much time to sit at home
and like, rail on me right now?
I don't even know you.
You could've just ignored it.
And like, I want your life,
if you have that kind of time.
Like you turn around and go,
I'm sorry your life is so little
that you're worried about me over here.
I love that.
- I liked that one, too.
Another one I have is if
someone calls you a cow,
you just turn around and move with them.
(laughing)
- I love that!